in the most recent episode of everything
pokemane touches somehow becomes
unnecessarily dramatic she talked
donations
specifically she talked about what she
feels are the manipulative
and unnecessary marketing tactics behind
donations
and showing sub counts on stream this
somehow chained into yet
another discussion about the perils of
parasocial relationships on twitch
when the dust settled hassan weighed in
with his takes
ms kiff gave his opinion and we're here
to break it all down
[Music]
want to see more videos like this one
like the video
leave a comment below then subscribe to
the channel
and hit that notification bell so you
never miss new content
ever again and if you have a story that
you want to see here on don't at me
send a tip to tips at the score dot com
on may 5th
pokemane streamed for roughly six hours
and on the surface
[ __ ] was pretty normal but about halfway
through the stream is when pokey dove
down
two twitch rabbit holes the weird sales
tactics that some streamers use to get
chat to donate and parasocial
relationships the part of the stream
that caused controversy online is when
she called out streamers who have their
sub counts
prominently displayed on their stream
overlay
here's the clip people who have like 50k
subs and there's
and they're like let's get 51k
[Music]
i really i hate
saying potentially controversial stuff
or telling people what to do
but i do personally find that a little
bit off-putting
to think like you make so much money and
you must
be very very well aware of this as being
such an easy and clear marketing tactic
to try to convince people to give you
even
more money that's crazy
is that really necessary here's another
clip of pokeman expanding on that idea
and trying to create a distinction
between
being greedy and wanting to make money
there's greediness
there's wanting to just accumulate a lot
of wealth which you know what
i don't even think that's a bad thing
but then there's like you have to
consider the fact
that when you're streaming
a lot of the wealth that you are
accumulating
is from other people's pockets typically
people that
make less money than you if i don't need
the money to sustain myself i don't want
to
further incentivize or try to use these
little marketing things to like squeeze
just a little bit more money out of
people
again just feels like unnecessary now if
you've ever watched pokemane you'll know
this perspective isn't that surprising
for a while now she's been vocal about
the fact that as one of the most popular
and well-paid streamers on twitch
she doesn't want or need a sub goal or
to have her sub count
prominently displayed on twitch
according to her it's just
well unnecessary she's gone so far as to
cap donations on her channel to five
dollars while encouraging her chat
to go spend those big money donations on
other streamers who need the cash
and despite being very clear and saying
that she wasn't calling out any
streamers specifically
the statements still caused controversy
especially with hassan and ms
kiff's fans see when she was talking
about the sub count
issue people in her chat were spamming
ms kiff and hassan's names
thinking that she was subtly talking
about them someone watching her stream
saw this happening in chat
also assumed it must be who she's
talking about and then clipped it
and titled it miz kif and hassan that
clip found its way to hassan who had a
pretty funny reaction to it a second
number there which apparently
was motivating people to
subscribe to me i have decided
that the best thing to do is this
there it is folks there it is
i think now we will have eliminated
this massive controversy now hassan was
quick to point
out that a he has no idea if pokemane
was actually calling him out
specifically
and b this entire situation for him
is a lose lose this is not the first
time that uh people have
been like why do you have your sub count
it's like
why do you have your sub counts on your
stream
why do you have it well it's because if
i [ __ ] don't have it then they're
like you [ __ ] grifter why are you
hiding your wealth you [ __ ] champagne
socialist
essentially what he's saying here is
that listen if
i don't show my sub count i get called
out for trying to hide the amount of
money that i make
but if i do show my sub count then i get
accused of trying to fleece my audience
eventually ms kiff chimed in with a
youtube video jokingly saying that
there's no way pokeman could be talking
about him
because he's nowhere near 50k subs and
also
he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's totally
shameless here's my philosophy on this
i'm shameless as hell i don't care i i
just
i this is the least shameless thing
about me
like this is the tip of the iceberg of
misgive
people put miss kiff in this and i'm
like bro
i get why hassan tries to farm subs
because that dude's not getting any
sponsors because he's political andy
i am the most shameless i do every
sponsor
i do anything that comes my way you give
me five dollars i'll do a
somersault now subbing to a streamer
typically is about showing your
appreciation for someone who entertains
you
literally for the entire day where
things can get
weird and manipulative as pokemane
points out
is when a streamer knowingly or even
unknowingly
takes advantage of the streamer fan
relationship
and milks it for money but again to be
clear pokeman never accused hassan
or ms kiff of doing this now here's
where the topic of what's called
parasocial relationships comes in and if
you watch twitch
it's a phrase you might have heard a lot
recently see this whole sub counts
donation conversation
stems from pokeman watching ludwig's
ever talked about video
i am not your friend which he published
back in december
and deals with parasocial relationships
i still haven't watched this video and
i've seen people in chat
message me about it so what is up now at
this point
some of you might be asking what the
hell is a parasocial relationship
well it can be described as any
relationship a viewer has
to a performer a celebrity a
media personality essentially a famous
person
more specifically these relationships by
definition
are one-sided you feel like you know the
person you're watching
on screen that you're somehow friends
with them
ludwig is likable pokeman is fun to
watch
but on the other side of that screen
they don't know you at
all you have a close relationship with
them they don't have that same close
relationship with you
hence ludwig's saying i am not your
friend listen loud and clear
none of your content creators your
favorite ones including me
are your friends so what got ludwig on
the subject of these relationships
well for a while now from twitter to
twitch to
youtube there's been this growing trend
of people talking
and making content about parasocial
relationships
because now that every big twitch
streamer is basically
a mega celebrity and not just some
random person
playing video games in their basement
they can have some pretty extreme
interactions with their fans ludwig in
his video
the one that pokeman was watching on
stream was in part responding to a
short dock made by a youtuber named
patrick atala
who was talking about parasocial
relationships and how they've affected
ludwig
now these types of relationships don't
have to be
bad all that the concept describes is a
one-sided interaction between a
viewer and someone more famous but when
someone has
a negative parasocial relationship with
a streamer
that they think they truly know the
person or that they're friends with them
they believe they're entitled to act and
speak in a way that crosses a line
here's pokeman realizing that the
behavior she's describing
is core to something called stan culture
which is like parasocial relationships
taken to the extreme
expectations is the huge one like yeah i
feel connected to all
like youtubers that i've watched for
years i don't have a level of
expectation of them
so if they don't meet that i will be
like mad
or upset or anything i feel like they
have maybe
oh my god actually that's kind of like
that's kind of the epitome of
certain stands there's certain groups of
stans
all of this parasocial [ __ ] isn't new to
most big streamers hell
pokey hassan mizkiff moist critical and
ludwig
have all dealt with unhealthy fandom in
some way
and it's not a coincidence that all of
these just chatting streamers i just
mentioned
have been dealing with this extensively
over the past year or so
since the whole point of just chatting
is built on constant and direct
feedback and interactions with an
audience some unhealthy relationships
are a guarantee
in some cases we've actually seen this
go to the next
level with some streamers being attacked
by
fans of another creator dream stands for
example
people who are obsessed with the
youtuber dream
a certain portion of his fan base has
harassed and attacked online
a bunch of different streamers at this
point including streamer caseytron
for often mild criticism of dream
things got so bad in her situation that
dream actually jumped on her stream
and condemned those fans and apologize
for their behavior
i denounce all hate for anybody i don't
know that's only for anybody
anybody anybody at all i denounce any
and all hate i don't support hate
but it wasn't just casey tron when
youtuber voice critical found himself
in some brief drama with dream and
therefore dream
stands back in february he made this
video talking about the potential
problems with these types of
relationships
there's nothing wrong with being a fan
of something or someone even a huge
really
big massive [ __ ] wumbo fan
of something but when you cross that
line into unhealthy obsession where your
entire day an entire online identity
is based around defending and fighting
for someone else's content who is a
total stranger mind you
no matter how big of a fan you are of
dream tommy or any of the big
minecrafters
they don't know you and you don't know
them you just like their content and
your entire happiness
is placed in their hands for you where
you're living vicariously through their
content you you have a problem
okay let's get back to pokeman in his
video that she's watching
ludwig jokes about what a streamer
funeral would look like and
pokeymane playing this idea out comes to
a situation that she
thinks is probably gonna happen at some
point streamed obviously
oh [ __ ] oh my god that makes me sad to
think that that will probably happen
at some point like the first
big streamer streamed funeral
she's right because like it or not
twitch's biggest names create
entertainment for gigantic groups of
people who believe
they have a special relationship with
that person and they just don't it's a
similar view that ludwig has had for a
while now he's described himself as
something similar to an episode of
television something to be consumed
something to be entertained by
not someone to have a platonic
friendship with
the way you would your best friend
honestly this drama
if you can even call it that is a side
effect of these one-sided relationships
watching streamers talk then spinning
their words into wild
theories that aren't even true that's
the twitch experience
just log into live stream fails that
[ __ ] is a cesspool
and god the day i show up there
i'm done
all right hold on
i want to like you remember that episode
of spongebob
where they create a box and they go to
different lands and [ __ ]
this is exactly what i want to do